on the Wednesday show I showed you a
truth social post truth essential yeah
of Donald Trump attacking his own former
press secretary Kaylee mcineny saying
that she was wrong about some of the
polling numbers and she's milk toast and
Trump misspelled milk toast and just
attacking his own former staffers and I
told you about all of the reasons that
making it a regular thing when he's
trying to build the staff and campaign
for president attacking former staffers
may not be a good idea Brian kilmead who
is another of the hosts on Fox and
Friends says that it was insane for
Donald Trump to go after Kaylee mcinanny
remember that Kaylee mcinanny is now a
co-worker of Brian kilmead she is a Fox
News employee kill me doesn't think this
is a good idea for Trump take a look he
flies off the handle for example for
example talking Kaylee mcanini is insane
she's one of the best press secretaries
ever Dana Perino as as Ari Fleischer
watching too I'm just saying she was
fantastic but she's she's an analyst now
she doesn't work for any campaign yeah
so Brian Kilmeade the most important
thing Kaylee mcinerney was not the best
press secretary ever maybe she was like
the most dishonest maybe the one who
told the most Lies per minute during
press briefing she was not the best
press secretary ever but he is
accurately pointing out that it is
insane for Trump to go after Kaylee
mcinanny and by the way if you believe
if Trump does believe that his final
press secretary Kaylee mcinerney was the
best one and did a good job I don't know
why you would want to alienate her this
early on in a Republican primary
campaign when not only might it be
useful to you to have her on your side
if maybe she decides hey I want to talk
about how great Trump is or whatever the
case may be and maybe you would try to
call on her again for some kind of help
in the campaign or staff or it just
seems so uh short-sighted and the
typical narcissism of Trump to be
attacking her because she read poll
numbers that Trump didn't like one other
really really funny thing from this
episode of fox and friends a Fox News
correspondent referred to Ron DeSantis
as Ron Des Sanctus on air which is
Trump's nickname for him I don't know
why I found this so funny but something
about it is Tuesday in New Hampshire and
of course Iowa is where everybody starts
that's why Des Sanctus and Trump are
there this week we'll see if Christy
doubles back to go there soon my guess
is he will that is that that is just
pure comedy the reporter referring to
him as the next thing you know they'll
be saying Ron de sanctimonious or even
Rob Des sanctimonious so I I'm very
interested in this
um I guess we would call it like the Fox
News factor in the Republican primary
because as we've said before
it's not that millions and millions and
millions of people are watching Fox News
all the time such that fox instantly
shifts public opinion in something like
a Republican primary but we have to
admit that Fox News has certainly set
itself up to be an agenda Setter when it
comes to the campaigns uh of Republican
candidates and political campaigns in
general and so whatever approach starts
on Fox first thing in the morning with
Fox and Friends it is more influential
than the audience numbers would suggest
is I think the way I would put it and as
a frame of reference we have right now a
situation where it's Trump 53 in the
primary de Sanctus 22 Nikki Haley in
third place at about four and a half
Mike Pence who's officially launching
next week just under four Vivek
ramaswamy at three or under three Tim
Scott's got 1.6 you know it kind of goes
down from there Chris Christie who will
also be announcing on Tuesday pulling a
very anemic one percent he's a one
percenter right now not in the way that
I think he wants to be and so this is
going to be a weird primary for sure I
think it will get significantly more
compelling with the entrance of Christy
and Pence and we will be watching all of
it we have a fantastic friday show for
you today I'm glad you're with us make
sure you're signed up on our website at
joinpakman.com we'll take a quick break
then we'll hear from some of you via
Discord and then the program will
continue
if you've been thinking about getting a
new mattress Helix sleep is where I
would start I've been sleeping on Helix
mattresses for years now I recommend
Helix to everyone which is why I wanted
them as a sponsor if you don't want to
take my word for it Helix has been
awarded number one mattress by both GQ
and Wired Magazine and one of the things
that makes Helix unique is their sleep
quiz I didn't really know what kind of
mattress would be best for me but you do
this short sleep quiz you answer
questions about your body type and your
preferences what position you like to
sleep in and Helix will match you with
the perfect mattress for you so you know
you're actually getting something
tailored to your needs instead of going
in blind like most people do I got my
Helix mattress designed to stay cool at
night since I hate getting hot while I
sleep shipping is always free you get a
hundred nights to decide whether you
like it my audience gets a huge 20
discount off of of all orders plus two
free pillows go to helixsleep.com Pacman
the link is in the description